Cicero's Tusculum disputations like the
works that we've looked at already on
the ends and on Duty's it is a work that
deals in particular with ethics and
tells us a lot about stoicism
particularly the middle stoicism of
Cicero's long time and the earlier old
stoma as well where you know Z narrow
and precipitous and clay entities are
the main figures you know this is a work
that's well worth reading in part
because although Cicero himself is not a
stoic he finds himself at one point
compelled to say that the Stoics might
actually be the the best philosophers at
least when it comes to ethics he says
however we may attack such men I have a
misgiving they're the only true
philosophers and so that's pretty high
praise coming from somebody like Cicero
now this is a work in five books it's
not a dialogue it's more of a flowing
discourse we could say that in that
biological but a dialectical way of
approaching the topic there is some
back-and-forth at the beginning of each
of the books with the chapters and it's
discussing several key topics for ethics
so you know it begins by talking about
should the the wise person fear death or
seek death as an evil and then it talks
about pain and we're not quite so
interested in those early books were
much more interested in books three and
four where Cicero is actually going to
be looking at disorders of the soul now
the way that he carries this out it is
influenced by the school of philosophy
towards which he says that he has a
greatest attraction which is that the
Academy the skeptical Academy which is
you know what a departed from Plato's
original Academy and ventured into a
kind of theory of probability and
weighting different
he says you know I'm a lawyer so this
kind of makes sense to me but unlike the
academic skeptics who tended to withdraw
from everything after they'd actually
consider the arguments and say well we
don't really know what you know which of
them is bad or worse Cicerone actually
will come down on this side or on this
side and he will tell you I don't like
this group over here the Peripatetic
because of this feature I like this
group the Stoics over here because of
this feature
he even has some grudging praise for the
Epicureans which is very rare for Cicero
but as you know they are into this work
so he examines a range of philosophical
positions on any one of the particular
topics and then they decide that well
which one is the best one and he
portrays it or he describes it and he he
develops it for his reader and so you
know thank goodness that he did that
because we don't have any of the text
that he is referring to so if we we
didn't have Cicero doing this we would
have lost all of this he also was taking
the Greek philosophy and he is
translating in depth once again into lap
where the you know the West that's where
the the center of gravity is going to
switch to now Cicero and a number of
points in this work says that he does
not like the literary style of the
stomachs he thinks that it's it's cram
it's too compressed in certain ways it's
it's not one order it's not what what
you know somebody who's influenced by
the resilience would do they tended to
be better speakers but he thinks that
the Stoics actually has certain things
completely right so he's going to
present and then endorse the stoic
position on quite a few things sometimes
with a few modifications of his own and
particularly on the issue of what we
call disturbances or in Latin / to
perturb a Tiana's of the soul now
you know if you don't like that sort of
theological language of the soul
it wasn't theological at the time it's
become so at our time you can think of
these in terms of disorders of the
personality disorders of the psyche
psychological problems and so Cicero is
in the realm of ethics but also in the
realm of psychology with this and he
thinks that the Stoics have put together
the best possible position so what I'm
going to do again in this this
particular video I'm not going to try to
go through this entire work you notice
that even figure them the other ones
again land on one side and English on
the other side so you know about half
the thickness is how long the book is
but I'm going to get on some of the key
ideas particularly in books three and
four about the stoic theory of emotions
and the problems that we we encounter
because of them
book three of the Tusculum disputations
begins by examining a question that's
going to run throughout that and and
book four as well about the things that
disturb us besides just pain physical
pain and besides death you know all the
things that upset us in the sense of
getting us upset and sister Oliver is
going to ask about the role of
philosophy in this obviously you know he
would be writing this if he didn't think
that philosophy had anything to do with
dealing with this and the question he's
asking is is there any treatment for
disorders of the soul this is still a
very valid question in our time when we
are attempted to say well of course
there's there's the whole domain of
psychology but you know if anything I've
ever gone to counseling or you you know
that one form of therapy or another you
know a lot of it can be quite hit or
miss and quite a bit of it that depends
not only on the method that's being used
and the assumptions that are at play but
on the skill of the practitioner the
therapist in helping you out with your
your problems and there's also a
subsequent question can you carry out
therapy yourself you know what we call
self-help is it possible to make strides
towards these things by using things
other than just clinical psychology by
you know turning to the humanities which
might know something about the human
soul might know something about a human
nature or the psyche since they've been
around for quite a while and so Cicero
bizarre asking a really important
question is there any sort of treatment
for the kinds of disorders of the soul
that really bother us that really
bothered us in our own lives where we
say what the hell is wrong with me
what's going on here and also bother
other people sometimes at this stage
where they say why you you gotta find
some professional help so what are the
kinds of things you know in broad
strokes that we're thinking about here
well motivations you know he talks for
example about people who
are subject to area being carried away
by desire of gained well we nowadays
call greediness is greediness in a
purely psychological problem the way
that a lot of sociologists and
psychologists and other people would
like to treat it or is it something that
we can get our hooks into by by using
some other means and methods it's a good
question you know our where were you
sort of naturally breed hardwired into
our brain or is there some malleability
to it he says lots of pleasure where
men's souls can be so disordered that
they're not far off on soundness of mind
is there no treatment that can be
applied to them so our motivations what
is actually driving us is there a
disjunction between what we say that we
value and what we actually do in fact
show that we value by our reactions and
that perhaps regret beliefs beliefs can
be on track they can be completely
erroneous and I think everybody knows
how hard it is to bring somebody
including themselves out of the state of
erroneous belief because there's a
tendency to ignore evidence to the
contrary to want to maintain that we're
right and when you start mixing in
motivations into that it gets even
tougher compulsion some people feel that
they have to do things that they they're
driven that they have no choice and then
finally the emotions how would the part
of the whole range of human emotions and
effects fit in with this you know
there's a very close connection in stoic
philosophy between emotions and beliefs
motivations all these things are
connected together some one reason why
one particular type of site you know
psychotherapy cognitive behavior therapy
or sometimes called rational emotive it
there's various names for it begins with
stoicism begins with that patinas
because
they the Stoics probably were right
about those sorts of things so Cicero
also observes it's worse to be sick to
the soul than to be sick in the body and
you might say well you know anybody
who's ever really been sick of the body
wouldn't say that sort of thing but you
know if you think about the the just a
psychological anguish that gets caused
by you know having yourself not really
put together by not understanding why
you behave the way that you do damaging
relationships acting like a kind of
person that you don't want to recognize
yourself to be all of these things can
be can be very problematic and only the
body where things are you know things
are complicated but things are also a
bit more straightforward it's harder to
work directly upon the personality or
the soul or the psyche whatever you want
to call it he says from for the for the
very fact that their attacks are
directed at the soul makes them hateful
a sick soul is always a strange cannot a
team or endure neither does it cease to
desire and to say nothing of others what
bodily diseases can be more serious prey
than these two diseases of distress and
desire the raises another interesting
issue as well
we don't heal the body by the body and
loan deciding what to do the the soul is
what heals the body the soul tells the
body take that medicine or let's do some
diagnostics and run some tests that's
the the mind or the soul at work and he
says how could we accept the notion that
the soul cannot heal itself
seeing is that the soul has discovered
the actual art of healing the body and
seeing that men's constitutions of
themselves as well as nature contribute
a great deal of the care in the body and
not all of them of those who have
submitted to treatment succeed at once
and making recovery as well whereas we
see them
contrary Souls which are ready to be
cured in obey the instructions of wise
men are undoubtedly cured you know when
somebody says oh you know I was really
badly off and I got my life together and
I figured things out because I actually
followed this I was ready to hear this
at the time you know whether it's in
psychotherapy where you know they always
say wait you know you can't really work
on your issues unless you you you're
ready to work on them unless you own it
you know that's sort of the contemporary
language of that or you know if you
think about other things if you've got
problems with money you go to your money
manager and they say well you know we
need to do some triage here of your
expenses if you're not ready to do that
you can't get cured you you have to be
willing to take the advice that's given
so this one was going to say philosophy
is an art of healing the soul now that's
an interesting thing to say because if
you think about a lot of the ways in
which philosophy is done today you would
not think that the people who are
academic philosophers are in the
business of healing the soul as a matter
of fact you may have walked out of some
people's classes saying I feel worse
they that I came in feeling and I don't
get anything out of this well that's
because of what's happened in the last
you know several hundred years with
philosophy and the kinds of people have
that bop egoism but in ancient times and
this is a common motif this is not just
a stoic but this is the Epicureans and
their resilience this is the skeptics
this is the plainest all these different
these different schools think that
philosophy is in part a therapeutic
exercise it is about making our lives
better by figuring out what really
matters and by figuring out what the
hell is wrong with us
so that we can align ourselves - you
know what's truly valuable there's two
things that he says it has
happen here if there's going to be this
feeling the song we actually listen to
and understand those who possess some
sort of knowledge who've worked out some
sort of reasonable ideas about this if
we're not willing to be open to it and
try it you know if we safe yeah listen
to these stomachs I'm going to read
their books but I'm never gonna actually
apply it in it we're not fully committed
now if you are fully admitted then
Cicero says these sort of problems can
be adequately dealt with the other thing
is that's really interesting we need to
become he says our own physicians if
we're going to work upon our souls it's
not enough to find some guru or to find
some you know teacher figure and or some
therapists and keep going back to them
over and over again that's just a state
of dependency it's a state of you might
say adolescence where we're not fully
grown up it's sort of like being and if
you want to use a classic case
alcibiades to Socrates women's
Alcibiades is with Socrates he can act
like a good guy because Socrates is
there saying hey what about this but as
soon as he goes off but as Ernie can't
apply it we need to take the philosophy
and learn minute adequately to
internalize it to become practitioners
not only for you know ourselves but
perhaps even for other people who come
along so we can as we say pay it forward
if somebody teaches you about stoicism
and that helps you get your life on
track maybe the next time that you see
somebody else struggling with some of
the same issues you help them out so
these two things are very important now
there's a big question that's being
raised here throughout the rest of these
two boys about the nature of the
emotions and desires doesn't wise person
the person who has practiced philosophy
who has understood it who
is you know what they call the sage the
person has got it together the person
we're trying to become this way if we're
doing you know what we're supposed to be
doing and stoicism does the widest
person experience emotions or desires
with the Greeks called hot thing the
Stoics have a pretty strong negative
answer to that and as we're going to see
they never rule of all emotions or all
effectivity but they do see many of the
emotions that we feel is to a major you
know to to great extents irrational and
likely to lead us astray so let's see
how Matt how that plays out
again the tusks of anticipation sister
Ogin is going to follow fairly closely
the stoic treatment of the disturbances
or as Cicero is going to translate this
term the kiribati I see the getting
stirred up within the soul he he sees
the emotions and these strong emotions
as morally problematic as liable to
cause us all sorts of trouble and some
emotions we already know are quite
troubling you know usually the ones that
return negative emotions but the still
works already been going to see certain
positive emotions it has liable to to
bring about trouble as well a bit later
he's going to talk about Zeno the Stoics
definition of emotion popping but here
he's just missing look it's a movement
to the soul and there is some sort of
disconnect with rationality it could be
that there's lacking rationality this
movement or it ignores rationality
reason says hey you should do this and
it goes off and does that or we're going
to disobedience rationality rationality
says look you're way out of a line you
should not be feeling this or you know
aiming at that
we're being averse to that and the
emotion essentially says I'm not doing
what you want I'm doing what I want and
the person who feels the emotion Hamm's
rationality within them but sometimes
the rationality just doesn't get a good
grip the stoic saw all emotions is
proceeding from some sort of ideas so
it's not like we just have feelings that
suddenly come over us and they're
totally you know without any sort of
connection to things it's not as if we
were to impinged upon it's about how we
judge realities but what we think is
going on so when we have an opinion that
there's something good at stake or in
clay then we feel certain basic emotions
we
certain emotional responses we can say
we experienced certain topic certain
passions as the Greece would say then
there's some that proceed from the
experience or the opinion or the
judgment that there's something bad
going on so when we think that there's
something that we take to be good we
feel joy or we feel a kind of pleasure
right put a lot of modalities of this
that we're going to get into later on or
you can read about in the book and what
makes us a problem for the Stoics is
that it's without measure reason isn't
giving some sort of measure some sort of
bounds to it there's nothing
intrinsically bad about feeling pleasure
or about feeling happy but it's the
sorts of things that we think are
happiness from and perhaps get too happy
about given the kind of things that they
are then that's for a present good so
something is there we actually feel that
that good feeling when it's not present
that are towards that good the thing
that we are thinking is good which could
actually be very bad for us we feel
desire or another way of putting this is
is lost right
lost not just in a sense of sexuality
but lost as as you know excessive desire
for something so those are the
modalities when we think something is
good and then when we think that
something is bad when we take it to be
that way even if perhaps it isn't you
know like when we have bitter medicine
which is going to cure us but we we
don't like to take it great example for
me is a 45 year old man there are a
number of pills that I'm supposed to
take each day sort of you know this is
good for this and this is good for that
and you know I have these pill boxes and
I don't like to take them so some days I
forget am I really forgetting or am I
just not getting around to it I'm averse
towards that sort of thing is it
reasonable for me to be adverse to them
no because it's totally for my good I
just don't like the way some of them
taste as they're going out just for a
moment
by the way for the whole day and I don't
like having to go off and take them at a
certain time
that's very unreasonable from a stoical
perspective but you get an idea what I'm
talking about
so proceeding from an opinion of things
being bad when we are in the presence of
something that we feel to be bad then we
feel a sense of distress or the Greeks
actually just said Lupe meaning pain or
you know they can cover a wide range so
think about it not just physical pain
but psychological pain we feel pained by
something embarrassment would be an
example of that sort of thing then in a
way that something is not present but we
think it to be bad we feel fear about it
so fear is the correspondent to desire
and distress is the correspondent to joy
these are four basic modalities of
emotions and the stur extended to see
things more or less working that way he
says these two classes exuberant
pleasure and lust springing from the
idea of good to stir the soul just as
the two remaining fear and distress
cause disturbances by the idea of evil
so you know the Stoics want us to if we
want to have a peaceful life we really
need to try to disassociate ourselves
from all of these now you know it brings
up an important question
aren't there any positive emotions and
the answer is yes a little bit later on
he's going to talk about this he will
say that this is where he brings up
xenos definition of disorder where he
says it's an agitation of soul alien for
my reason and contrary to nature so he
says that there there are some effects
that we can feel that are actually good
for us to feel so what makes them that
way well the thing that corresponds to
joy or delight which is actually good
for us if we get rid of this without
measure part then what we get is
what the Greeks called blue laces and
which we might translate as rational Jew
away I'm sorry
that's that goes here national desire or
wish laces right we can feel a sense of
delight that is rational so I should
also prepare rationale in the historic
stage the wise person will feel this
it's not going to disturb their soul
it's going to be in line with reasons
that's not something that is really
stirring them up rational desire would
be a great example this would be the
desiring something with the if fate
permits it sort of clause added to it I
would like to have my meatloaf
sandwiches tonight for dinner if that's
going to work out if it's not going to
work out that I'm not going to like
being a little upset because my desire
is unsatisfied right what about with
with respect to these things can we feel
some sort of rational some sort of
rational aspect with respect to them
well it was respect to fear he says we
can he goes around and he says here
here we go since we did naturally desire
to good in the same manner as we
naturally turn away from evil and such a
turning away when rational would be
called precaution and has constantly
consequently found a wise person when
dissociated from reason it becomes fear
so precaution
is something that a stoic would still
feel if they've got them all together
what about the stress is the wise person
going to feel distress
the Stoics said to know there is no
rational way the feeling distress there
is some rationale for why you feel the
way that you feel when you feel the
stress may feel like upset but it's not
actually rational in the full sense to
feel that and so if you are practicing
the precepts of stoicism and and you
know confining yourself to just what you
actually have control over what what is
your business you are not going to end
up feeling bad in that sense because
you're not going to assess anything as
bad for you then other people will like
when you lose some money you're not
going to see that as something worth you
getting upset about whereas you
certainly can take precautions you
certainly can't have a rational amount
of joy in now gaining some money that
now you can do good things with you can
have a rational desire for being
financially solvent but if you're stoic
and you're really thinking this out
concert you know in consequence you are
not going to have any sort of distress
that you feel of course that set a limit
point interestingly enough if you think
about it we as as people who might be on
the latest Oasis it might be a way to
this age certainly can feel the stress
over the fact that we are still feeling
distressed we can feel bad about the
fact that we haven't made as much
progress as we didn't like to made
especially after you know in my case
quite a few years of studying this sort
of thing and so it would be in a certain
assessed rational for me to feel that
but it wouldn't be rational for me to
keep on holding on to that in a morbid
kind of way I would want to gradually
phase that out you can say now Cicero
himself I
like to point out doesn't actually go
along with the Stoics on this he thinks
that the wise person will in fact feel
some degree of distress in life and so
he's going to depart from Orthodox you
know Stoics like sit like Zeno and
Christmas and even you know the the
middle Stoics that he talks about he's
going to say I think that it's it's
quite possible to be a wise person and
feel a sense of distress in life
with any of the four basic emotions or
just disorders disturbances per to bacio
nays of the soul that sister was
discussing here gaining these ideas from
the Stoics there's a possibility of
going into much greater depth and detail
with it and that is part of what he
thinks
the Stoics really excelled in doing was
taking each of these and breaking them
down into their specific modes or parts
and I only put the ones up here with
respect to desire or libido then he has
to do with various types of anger or
aggression or ill will towards person he
also includes a discussion of greed in
their lost desire to be with the person
or see a person in temperance in general
but I'm not going to worry so much about
that I just wanted to give you an
impression of how detailed the Stoics
can get about this or the thing with
this kind of analysis and notice that it
all comes back to anger in one way or
another so there's anger there's IRRI in
Latin which is desire for punishing a
person thought to have inflicted an
undeserved injury upon oneself or those
connected with one this is a typical
definition of anger back in ancient
times Aristotle was the person who
actually came up with it and a lot of
other people are running with it so it's
a desire and it's oriented towards some
sort of thing that it valued some sort
of thing that sees as good in this case
the good is actually the bad of somebody
else if I'm going to punish you I want
to inflict some pain upon you or some
injury or humiliation something in
return and it's for punishing a person
thought to have done something else do
you see how important the act of judging
of making opinions about things of
imagining it is for for the way in which
anger works it has a kind of desire he
goes on he has
for other things that he talks about I'm
actually I'm going to read you the Latin
terms because they're they're quite cool
I really like this there there's zero
which is anger right and then we have X
can this condom Cynthia which the Greeks
called through Moses right that is rage
that's over translating it in English
and this is anger that springs up and
suddenly shows itself I'm so mad at you
right that's that's rage now it's a
motive banker so it does also have this
desire to punish a person it does also
have the judgment that somebody did some
undeserved inquiry about injury not
inquiry but when a person flies into a
rage like we said when they have a short
temper that's the sort of thing that
that's happening right hatred there we
go in a podium is in veterans anger
anger that just won't go away
anger that is lingering when anger
congeals or consolidates itself within
the soul of the person and tends to turn
into hatred in a min ki jiye literally
the opposite I make you know which is
friendship the you know bow down there
think about how you treat friends and
I'm just thinking about how you treat
enemies that's where we get the word
enmity from from enemies anger watching
for an opportunity for revenge anger
that's just waiting for that person to
slip up so I could stick it to him
that's what empathy is and again still
involving the desires still evolving the
idea that I deserved an injury
finally graph the Latin term for this is
discordia what it would a wonderful way
of putting it discordia the opposite of
Concord and also a sort of disordered
heart the core the cornice is then you
know messed up
this is anger greater bitterness
conceived in the
most heart and soul where a person is
just filled with that anger all the time
and can't let it go perhaps it's not
even visible to somebody else but it's
their smouldering away like a fire
underneath the turf all of these are
modes of desire and they can all be
distinguished apart from each other and
that can actually be quite helpful not
only for literary purposes is the person
being driven by rage or right-half or
anger but so that we can figure out what
the hell's going on with us so we don't
have to feel things if we can identify
them if we can figure out how they work
and what sort of judgments are being
made that are leading to this we have
the possibility of freeing ourselves
from these emotions and from all the
other modalities of excessive desire
that can be felt
the dimension of hamon is particularly
important when thinking about these
sorts of issues like Cicero is in the
tusculum disputations in part because we
are creatures who don't exist just at
one particular moment we should never
really judge ourselves even in one
single moment but but in a broader
perspective we are the way we are by the
time that we start thinking about that
because we have existed over time and
we've made decisions some good some bad
we've had experiences and all those
things eventually become habitual or at
least some of them and so Cicero was
going to say one reason it is not
applied as a remedy and when we're not
you know thinking in terms of philosophy
the badness that comes from these
disorders these these emotions that we
feel these perch of box cojones it seeps
into the body and he says it circulates
through the veins and fastens itself
upon the vital organs no you know is
this physiology that we would accept the
day probably not too much but we
certainly do think that neural pathways
become established over time don't we
because that's you know what everybody
wants to talk about these days
neuroscience of the possibility of
changing these sorts of things well
that's very similar to what Cicero was
talking about here you know he does by
the way concede that some people by
nature by the way that they're they're
born by the sort of brain chemistry that
they have they may be more prone to what
emotional state than to another well he
thinks that our environment and our
choices and what we tell ourselves about
our choices has an incredibly important
role in forming who we are and the kinds
of ways we think and feel about things
he also says that we end up with a
habitual disposition to feeling
disordered emotions to having them
easily provoked and this can become what
we call vices vices are or you might say
complexes of not just habit
but also erroneous beliefs about what's
good and what's bad the person who is
vicious has actually got some not just
ordinary mistaken views but some
seriously mistaken views that are going
to impede them from being able to
recognize what the genuine good is and
with the genuine pianist which makes
them prone to feeling these sorts of
disorders the system was going to go on
and he's gonna say it's really hard to
get rid of device it's much more painful
to by the way to get rid of it if you're
at least conscious of it then it is just
to get to deal with an emotion as it
arises it's over time that we become the
kind of people that we are and then he
says a couple other things that are very
interesting I'd like to say just to wrap
up you know he's talking he's made a
couple points in the work of saying the
Stoics are really right about this right
about that and he said that and this is
a book for take out disorders and above
all they're asked ability the result is
of the stoic seem to be talking nonsense
but as it is their line of argument is
to assert that all fools are man in the
same way that all not stinks and then
his interlocked courses surely not
always one doesn't always stink then he
says stir it up and you'll see similarly
the irascible man is not always angry
but rouse it now you will see him in a
rage again this command and Rask ability
in ears when it's got back home what is
it like with wife with children with
household or do you think it's useful
there as well as battle is there a thing
that the disordered mind can do better
than the equitable mind or is anyone at
all able to be angry without disorder of
mine therefore as all my Caesar who
world defects our countrymen have done
well to give the name of morose to a
rascal not alone because no vice is more
degraded than ever a stability this is
Cicero
taking a very strong stand against anger
e-cicerone agrees with the Stoics on
this he thinks that the Aristotelian is
are way off base and that the Stoics
have got the right
towards anger anything can very easily
like any other of the disordered
emotions following to this this pattern
of ice and when that's the case you know
you can you know if we say that a
certain person is vicious it doesn't do
you any good to say well I don't see him
acting like that just put him in other
context and see how he behaves the
person who is greedy the person who is
lecherous the person who is too prone to
make too big of a thing out of the the
problems of lighting it's sad all the
time over trivial stuff
although these sorts of things the
person who is you know a coward the
person who is rash and flora tea all of
these sorts of things can become parts
of our character the remedy is to apply
reason to use rationality to restructure
our desires our athletes so that they
make sense so that they lead us to the
way that we want to be so that we can be
free of these disorders free of perch of
acciones free of all sorts of being
shaken up by them and we can with a
tranquil life